foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yes
welcome everyone thank you for listening
to this third video stream of that space
i'm with uh rahman campos oyera creative
director hello everyone mike yazzy jan
art director i'm for content for that
space today mo more
uh the art direction of the original
dead space was extremely strong it had a
distinctive visual signature that helped
set it apart from other games
we'll start off our presentation today
with mike
talking about the visual pillars and how
it's used as the foundation for the game
then we'll move at uh looking at assets
that was created by our team through
videos that explain how we use these
visual pillars
from an architectural and environment
pieces
from lighting from vfx and characters
and just like last times we're going to
wrap all of this up with some in-game
look at one of their more iconic rooms
of the ishimura
that room's going to turn on so it's
going to be pretty amazing
all right
just like past live streams there is a
disclaimer we are still pre-alpha so
mainly what it means is that the content
that you'll see is going to be uneven in
terms of quality
there's going to be assets showcasing
gyms from the editor straight out
looking placeholder or some buggy stuff
that's normal for the stage or the
project that we're in there's going to
be some amazing stuff also there's also
going to be some pretty amazing stuff
hopefully that you agree with us
um
however we're progressing very well for
our alpha deliverables uh just two weeks
ago we were able to do our first full
walkthrough of the game
where all content was present and next
week we are going to do this with our
community council
the community council for those of you
don't know is a group of passionate fans
that have been with us since early in
the conception of the project providing
feedback and getting undisclosed access
to to the game that we're making
and just like past live streams we
actually have a member of a community
council that's here with us today
we have blaine smith from bangor tv
joining us hey blaine how are you
good happy to be able to
talk about some of this and uh
definitely happy to be able to uh you
know uh have this sweet baseball tee
from y'all featuring the ishimura
although i am getting a little insecure
watching uh how it how it fits roma
versus how it fits the rest of us not
quite filling out the same way you have
more tattoos
the jealous factor
[Laughter]
so
all right well let's kick it off right
let's uh let's start yeah absolutely so
we're talking about art today which i
mean is definitely one of the strongest
aspects aspects of dead space and of
course we have a fantastic guest from
motive here we have we have an art
director in the house but i don't know
if necessary necessarily all of us will
know exactly what an art director does
so do you want to fill us in on uh on
what your work on the dead space game
has been so far
sorry i got no audio so what's not to
write till then oh okay what's in our
direction
that's a good question so um what i
usually do uh is my day-to-day is i
collaborate with roman and phil
and the other directors and the leads on
the project
i work very closely with the art team
i provide them with guidelines to make
sure that the visuals look unified
across the game and i maintain the
artistic vision throughout the project
to keep a consistent look in all our
chapters so i think that kind of
summarizes what i do
i think and uh from what i understand
this also actually isn't your first dead
space game
oh we actually lost audio from lane
oh no no no no
you have to you have to mine
all right well well actually we'll kick
it off on our side until we resume like
the issue with uh the microphone i think
it's on our side so uh mike why don't
you walk us through actually absolutely
direction that's great so what we're
going to do today is through various
images and videos
we're going to show you how we're
honoring the legacy and staying true to
the original game
uh so what we want to do first is look
at some of the art pillars that define
and influence the dead space look
uh so the first and most important one
is horror storytelling so even though
the dead space universe is set hundreds
of years in the future the main art
pillar is horror as opposed to sci-fi or
fiction
um
since it's so important to us we really
are like doubling down on that and we
just can't
two slides
of the locations are all affected by
this pillar
i mean it also influences the look of
the necromorphs uh gore dismemberment
and corruption
uh it goes as far as influencing the
design of the weapons right because
they're based on power tools
uh so that kind of sums up the first
pillar uh the second key visual pillar
is one of immersion so to be scared
you have to believe what's in front of
you just like in the original dead space
our goal is to always maintain a sense
of immersion to keep the player
captivated
and the settings believable and grounded
so the third pillar
is
so a lived-in world now since the dead
space universe is rich in environmental
storytelling
every object tells a story and has a
meaning so when you look around you're
on the ishimura you see the effects of
aging and weathering
everywhere you look so
another key thing is resource
conservation right that is key in the
universe and all the objects are
repurposed and reconfigured
so that's quite important to us so those
are the main three
visual pillars of that space it's not
it's not a new ship like it's been used
and around exactly yeah 16 years old
it's interesting when you say that the
world because
you see that what we've learned from
this is
i know you're talking but we still can't
hear you so that's something that we're
trying to resolve on our site
so but actually like one of the things
that we're
we're going to look at that follows it
is actually there's a lot of symbolism
right in the original dead space yes uh
so let's have a look at what
what roles it plays in in the art for
that space absolutely so there is a lot
of symbolism in that space and i want to
show you some of that and how it
influences the look and mood of the game
so for example we've we've talked about
this on many occasions during the
community council before
the ishmura is like a haunted house and
the design is influenced by the gothic
architecture
with lots of evocative shapes
so that's quite prominent
the second one is how ishimura is a
character it's a broken machine that is
alive and sick
both physically and mentally and the
user interface is its voice
sort of talks to us um
the locations they're purposely built
with low ceilings and narrow spaces
to make it feel claustrophobic
like you're trapped inside a maze we'll
see later how we actually reinforce that
absolutely effects yes
and then lastly uh the necromorphs right
since you're on a haunted ship a haunted
house
they're like the ghosts that haunt isaac
and torment him on his journey to hell
all the way to his final destination
so that essentially summarizes uh some
of the key uh
you know symbolism that you saw that you
find in the game
um what we wanted to do next is you know
cover like now that we've covered the
symbolism we want to look at how we're
updating the classic by looking at
visual upgrades for the remake
so what we could do is maybe play the
video
of the props and weapons
so in 2008
the original dev team created a game
that was amazing for its time and it's
our commitment to respect their vision
and rebuild on the same pillars
we're taking the original game and
building the gen 5 version and keeping
the recipe that we all know and love
as you can see from these before and
after examples we're using the original
art
as a starting point as we redesign and
remake the assets from the ground up
we're retaining the overall shape and
look of these objects to respect the
dead space art direction
and we're adding more functionality
layers of detail
and a lot more realistic materials
so as you can see in these examples of
the before and afters you see time and
time again we're doing that
now you see the power tools yes
i can't wait to show you a gorgeous
building game and of course one of our
favorites i know blaine you love this
one
[Laughter]
the ripper when it cuts people in pieces
well not people with necromorphs and
pieces
it's gory it's fantastic
awesome
cool so um so what what i'd like to talk
a little about about now is uh the part
that we've all been waiting for uh to
show how we're creating our visuals
in four in-depth videos so the goal here
is to give a sneak peek of our art
process by showing work in progress
captures from software
so in the first video
the environment team will take us behind
the scenes and show how our chapters are
constructed from beginning to end
for the second video the vfx team is
going to follow up with some pyro and
fluid simulations in gyms and some
quality upgrades
next up character team will present how
they built the level 3 engineering suit
and of course the slasher
and in the last video the lighting team
will walk us through some of the cool
tech behind the lighting in the game
including real-time global illumination
and volumetric lighting
so a lot to come there oh yeah there's a
lot of goodies
all right well let's kick it off with
the environment video yes
hi my name is roy twizon and i am the
associate art director for the dead
space remake
today i want to talk to you about the
environment art process
how we are remaking the game with our
new tools techniques and pipelines
and finally do a demo in the frostbite
engine on how we took a room from the
legacy version to our current work in
progress
today we are going to look at the mri
room in chapter 2.
when dead space was released more than
14 years ago the visuals were great it
set the bar high for its time
but since then technology has evolved
and with that it allowed us to remake
the game and really accentuate the main
pillars of horror immersion and a
lived-in world
let me quickly go over our process with
you
on the environment side we break down
our pipeline into six phases that go
from l0 to l5
l0 is our r d phase where we analyze the
original game and identify what we can
remake this area either through gameplay
visuals sound etc based off any changes
we would do some exploration concepts to
improve on the art pillars
l1
this phase is when the area will be
playable with rough block out of the
visual intentions
when recreating a room in frostbite the
artist will break it down into kits
pieces that they can use to build the
room
think of this as lego blocks
they will be simple shapes sizes that
represent the theme of the room
l2 is where details and colors are added
into the kits to support the thematic of
the area
large props are staged and the initial
mood will be set
l3 is where we start to update the
different pbr materials to a more
realistic look
add more props to support the theme and
refine the lighting and vfx
you should start to get that immersive
feeling by having the area more
relatable and believable
l4 is where we add all the narrative
elements
all the architectural kits get a
polished pass with a wear and tear small
props signs markings blood stains dirt
and grime are added to get that lived in
world feeling and give that horror
storytelling element
of where we are in the production of
this area we are here in the beginning
stages of our l4 phase
now that you know how we work we want to
next demonstrate how we will remake
these assets
here is an example of a legacy you hear
the video here are some of the other
hearing aids
to get that immersive feeling throughout
the ship
we want to show functionality
rivets in the metal to show how it was
put together
latches on the window frames to show how
the workers can remove it if it ever
needed to be repaired
the variation in our pbr materials the
way light reacts to different types of
painted metal versus the raw metal
underneath
more realistic light fixtures
the dirty glass cover protects the light
sources giving that depth and more
realistic feel add more shape and depth
to the model to give it that believable
look
to get that old live-in ship look we
added wear and tear to the paint metal
and dirt accumulation in areas that
would not normally get cleaned
now that we've highlighted a few
examples of how we're going to remake an
asset in our next section we want to put
you in the seat of an artist and show
you how our tools techniques and
pipeline works
hi there i'm evan ivanovic senior
environment artist on the dead space
remake and i'm going to give you a
closer look at how we make assets for
the ishimara
here is an example wall asset as it
passes through all the various stages of
production l1 raw model made to specific
metrics for maximum reuse l2 further
refined modeling and color pass added
l3 more modeling details are added
custom masks are baked to control grime
and wear using in-engine tools
l4 fine trim and embedded details are
added as well as beveled edges
next we will have a look in maya to see
how the color pass is achieved
here in maya we'll be using the palette
uv tool created by our tech team to help
change the colors of our wall mesh on
the right hand side we can see the uv
coordinates of the model which
correspond to the meshes faces as i
click the different swatches in the uv
palette tool the uv shells are moved to
different quadrants resulting in a color
change by using this palette system we
are able to keep colors consistent to
art direction and swap in different
palette textures for each district theme
such as clean industrial and public
depending on the assets used within the
ship
now let's dig into how some of our mesh
details are achieved
here in blender i'm going to show you
one of our trim sheet texture sets i
made by rebuilding and remixing details
from the original dead space into a new
texture layout as we can see this
texture set uses parallax occlusion
mapping which allows you to mimic depth
and details on an otherwise very simple
geometry
one technique we have explored for
applying these texture sets on models is
using the third party add-on decal
machine to define specific parts of the
texture set to a library which can then
be easily swapped and adjusted on the
model as you can see this technique
makes it fun to try out different trim
combinations and can produce some
interesting results
here we will apply the same library to
the wall example we saw before through
use of these trim textures we are able
to quickly try different approaches and
create consistent details
we try our best to focus on how these
models would actually be constructed
creating panel lines where pieces meet
and connect as well as adding handles
and access points where parts could be
removed for maintenance and cleaning
hi i'm xavier perrot and i am the lead
environment artist on the dead space
remake
i will be talking more in the details
about our approach to level art and how
we set the tone of the different areas
of the ship and tell the story of the
ishimura through our environments
we have now the architectural modules
modeled and their mask baked using our
engine tool
the masks will define how the wear and
grime build up on each of the modules
you can tell how the edges are scratched
and how rust sits in the creases
the architectural shader reads those
masks and by tuning the parameters of
the master shader we can control the
amount of wear and grime in a whole
section of the ship at once
the shader defines the ground state of
the architecture visuals but at this
point it all looks the same everywhere
the well masking volumes come in play
they are fully scalable and can be used
in many ways for multiple layering
effects
we can increase the amount of wear or
rust built up on the assets
or even add new layers on top like water
or dust for instance
of course these techniques are better
applied once the assets are put in
context in the level
tuning the master shader and adding
volumes of world masking are an integral
part of defining the storytelling of the
ship and how it has age over time
with a growing library of architectural
modules they can be assembled to fully
build all the sections of the ishimura
as one big interconnected ship in line
with our metric guidelines
then comes the
then comes the main lighting intentions
and the props dressing
we always ask ourselves what the
function of that room is
how do we make it believable and tell
the story of the people that live there
and how the events took place
projected decals of labeling and gore
are tip further we can add a few well
masking volumes to wear down the floor
in a realistic way where people used to
stand and walk around in this setup
maybe a water canister fell over near
that desk and leaked all over the floor
but that was a while ago and rust built
up all around it
after seeing our pipeline tools and
in-engine demo
using the small room besides the mri
machine you can see in this before and
after comparison
we remade this room to accentuate the
art pillars even more
we want the player to believe that the
ishimura crew worked here
that the functionality of this room
makes sense
and you can even imagine yourself
working in this environment
if i take this part of the room for
example
before there used to be some shelves
lockers and props around the wall with
some writing on the ground
we remade it to have more immersive and
believable theme
we made this corner of the room more
functional by adding an examination bed
with medical equipment
we gave that lived-in world by aging the
walls and floors with some wear and tear
added dirt and grime
this is the oldest functioning mining
ship
we wanted to make sure that came through
in the environment
finally
we injected the horror pillar into this
room with a bloody narrative scene on
the bed and floor
we want to insinuate that something
horrible happened here and give that
sense of danger looming around every
corner
thank you for joining us on this
behind-the-scene look at the environment
art process
hey we're back
so blaine can we hear you now do you
hear us
i hear you and we hear you
all right
hey what's up we got comms working nice
now isaac get to the engine room
there's work to be done there yes it's
the shimura right
you know it wouldn't it wouldn't be dead
space if everything was working smoothly
yeah so you know this was just a little
easter egg for you in the chat thanks
for coming out and catching the live
stream showing you that true dead space
experience and uh man i you know we
we in the council got to play a little
bit of this early on and that was a that
was a much emptier room when we walked
into it a lot less scary uh it's really
cool to see that
to keep with that horror pillar you're
creating these little scenes in rooms
these little stories
is is the story department working with
the art department to like write little
things like that absolutely uh our
narrative group works with our level art
group and make sure that they're
collaborating on and looking at every
single chapter of the game area by area
and coming up with little stories that
they want to tell to make it feel like
uh each area has life and there's a
story and just to show how the crew
lived right before the events uh that
you see in the in the game and of course
after the attack and so on so uh there's
a lot of work that that's placed there
uh by the team as they're crafting this
it's a real collaborative effort between
narrative level design level art every
audio everybody is is really involved
into that and not only we're looking at
what we want to do but also most of the
time we're looking at what was in the
original and often we keep that and
enhance it sometimes based on some
evolution of the narrative that we want
to make we can
slightly change or evolve
those elements
but that's really our goal is to keep
that pillar of the original that was
each room
each corridor each places had something
unique
something you could remember that room
or that place because of that sound
because of that writing on the wall
because of the blood of the little
narrative in that place and that's
something that we want to keep and that
we want to uh to reinforce going further
yeah it's really great to hear about all
the teams working together on this and i
and i love thinking about someone just
walking around the office with an
absolutely terrifying notebook of little
room
see what happened in one seat dear god
yes
bible yes pretty much
and that's one of the opportunities like
we saw in the video is that we look at
an area that existed before and how can
we amp it up and enhance it right uh to
to
have a richer experience in the
storytelling
and then uh one of the interesting
things is that you guys are kind of
talking about making things look
realistic and usable but of course it's
not realistic and usable this is a
planet cracking mining ship how do you
approach making something look as though
you can picture yourself using it and
operating this when you can't actually
because it doesn't exist and you can't
use it or operate it yeah well that's
that's big part of what we talked about
originally the horror pillar is making
sure that
it feels scary but at the sign at the
same time it is relatable right so uh
when you look at the locations the props
that are there uh we intentionally make
sure to keep them feeling realistic as
realistic as possible uh and not going
too sci-fi because if we do that then it
alienates the player and you don't
really know and you can't relate to that
environment so we purposely make sure
that we continue in the same vein of
keeping objects whether it's the mri
room or fire extinguisher or chairs and
so on as as real to us as possible so we
can relate to that and we can be
immersed in the world and then of course
we'll be we'll be scared when we have
like a necromorph that comes out of
nowhere right we'll have our guard down
it's about making these places dustin
level for the player that can project
yourself in trying to
imagine how those things work like if
there is massive engine okay where's the
the console that control that if it's
the mri same thing where the people
actually working with this stuff what
are the tools they are using whereas the
ceiling all those kind of things that's
the elements that are making those
places believable even though a real a
real spaceship does not necessarily
exist or at least not in this form it
still has to be functional right so so
when we do concepts for these pieces
that are more complicated or the hero
pieces it is a lot uh the work that the
concept teams are looking at really
trying to make sure that this machine
would work how would they how would it
work so that it's it is functional when
we put it in the game and it makes sense
yeah it just seems like everybody
everybody on this team has to know a lot
of different things
um we've been talking a little bit you
know we had some we had some uh we had
some little explosions tech wise i think
you guys also have some explosions to
show us
oh yeah that's a good segue
it's not the first time you do this
so let's let's take a look at the vfx uh
video
hi everybody i'm greg herd rudder and
i'm the lead vfx artist on the dead
space remake what i'm going to show you
today is some of the atmospheric and
environmental vfx that have been created
by our team
these are vfx such as fog smoke and
pyrotechnics that help populate the
ishimira and help tell the dead space
narrative
now before i show you what we're doing
let's take a look at the original dead
space and what they did for their
environmental vfx they did an amazing
job in setting a very desaturated color
palette with everything very muted and
everything feels very natural
nothing feels fantastical or takes you
out of that horror mood
for the remake we wanted to stay true to
this but look for opportunities to push
things further using modern day
techniques the original was quite
limited in terms of complexity of vfx
while we have a lot more room to move
the first thing i'd like to show you is
how some of our vfx can react to
changing environmental conditions
so here we have a debug scene and as you
can see it's pretty much empty with some
sparks and drips
these are pretty typical vfx that we'll
see in a number of locations in the
ishimura to show damaged areas
what i'd like to show you is how these
effects can react to changing
environmental conditions and in this
case what happens when gravity is
disabled
i'm going to disable the gravity here
and right now we can see that these vfx
are behaving differently and they're no
longer falling to the floor
now there's a lot more happening than
just the gravity i can make a number of
artistic choices as to how the vfx
behave
for example with the drips i wanted to
extend their lifetime so they spread out
across the room rather than disappear
quickly
for the sparks i reduced their turbulent
motion because when they had a lot of
turbulence it felt like they were still
in normal conditions
there's a number of things that we can
modify so that when the player interacts
with these effects they'll feel
believable and well integrated
these little details can really add up
to help tell the story and make the
ishimira feel like it's alive
next i'd like to show you a little bit
about our pyrotechnics pipeline
i'm looking at one of our explosion
effects
this is something we'd see when a small
prop is getting destroyed
here we have a bunch of different
elements like a fireball smoke sparks
and debris i'll hide a few of these so
we can concentrate just on the fire and
smoke
i'll set this to loop so we can see it
continually playing
something that is important to dead
space is that we have a lot of dark
environments that have changing lighting
conditions we were finding that elements
such as fire and explosions would look
way too bright when the environment was
dark and then would be barely visible
when the environment was brighter so
what we had to do was to be sure that
our source pyrotextures were rendered in
full hdr quality to ensure that the
final image would contain the full range
of brightness values
i'll slow this down a bit so we can see
things a bit more clearly
if i zoom in the exposure will adjust so
it doesn't appear too blown out and when
i back off it will readjust
if i change this to a darker environment
you'll see that we don't get a crazy
amount of over brightness and we're
still able to see a lot of detail in the
texture
and finally i'll go to pitch black
it still holds up and behaves naturally
so this all means that we can play a lot
with the lighting in our environments
and the vfx will still integrate into
the experience well and be legible by
the player
the final thing i wanted to show is our
interactive atmospherics
so here i am in another test map
i have a few debug lights floating
around so we can see what's happening
here i'll just back up and start one of
our steam effects
so what do we have here
it's a volume based 3d simulation it
exists inside a container and density
and velocity values are pushed around to
create what we see here
something that's cool about this
simulation is that it lives in the
physics world so if the player walks
through it it will interact
also if i pick up an object like this
battery
it will also behave quite naturally
this will work if i spawn an enemy i
disabled its ai so it won't attack me
as you can see the steam will collide
and interact with him too
this effect also works quite well with
our lighting and renders with the rest
of the fog we have throughout our game
this can be used in a number of cases
we can create a steam or smoke effect
like this
or we can cover the floor with a thin
layer of interactive fog
in some cases we can even fill an entire
room with a cool simulation like this to
give us some interesting and terrifying
gameplay situations
so thanks for watching i hope you
enjoyed seeing some of the vfx we're
working on
huh
[Laughter]
oh man that fog when you first showed it
to us oh wow it just
so i i've never been so excited about
fog in my life uh it's crazy to think
that you know one of the first truly
great uh horror sci-fi movies
alien came out almost 40 years ago and
that scene where they step out into the
eggs and there's that layer of fog that
they disturb and now we're finally 40
years later able to kind of do that kind
of stuff in video games uh how are you
planning on on using this uh
in the gameplay
so of course something we're gonna use
for to create specific ambience in rooms
for the storytelling and this kind of
elements but in gameplay where it's
really amazing it's in sequences like
for example the contamination chamber in
chapter 3. so when you enter that room
the contamination sequence starts and
the room fills with fog and the fog
stays at around one meter of the floor
and where it gets awesome it's when you
actually have a lurker
dropping from the ceiling inside the fog
and now you see the poof of smoke when
he gets inside it and you're like where
the [ __ ] where is he going
and you start to shoot at it and you're
trying to find it and at some point you
see those three turn tackles
coming out of this the fog and those
moments are really really scary and
that's the the kind of thing we're
looking at with uh with that technology
it's how we can use it to reinforce
ambience and really scary gameplay
moments like that
yeah it's it's it's so cool to see all
the
you keep bringing out all this
technology and it's and it's not
technology that's just oh hey we can do
this now and we're doing it because we
can do it everything really is tied to
like a narrative element every time
you're like we can do this but here's
why we're doing this and another area
that's that's getting such a huge
upgrade is you know one
one of the challenges the original dead
space had was zero g is is very
difficult to do and obviously it was it
was limited in a lot of ways and then
dead space two
a bit more of the shackles came off and
then now uh up to current day you know
you're having floating sparks and uh and
and and all the little the changes to
the the water and the vapor in zero g it
does it feel kind of like you have your
your shackles removed and you're kind of
able to finally make the zero g
experience you kind of dreamed of yeah
it's again it's really about immersion
and the fantasy of being space and
unbelievable is that that is and so
that's one of the reason we change a
little bit how the the zero g was is
working in terms of player mechanic from
compared to the original that's why we
choose to uh to go the same way as dead
space two and three went with zero g and
now
with vfx with art with physics etc it's
about
improving the immersion of of zero g and
not only improving the immersion when
you're in zero g
but also putting the emphasis at the
moment where it changed from one g to
zero g and that's something we're doing
in the in some areas of the ship and we
wanted that to be really visible and
kind of a war moment for the players
it's also giving us the opportunity to
do all the things we've wanted to do
with that space now we get to do those
things we really get to enhance all
those areas bring more life to them
bring more immersion
and always dialing up the horror as well
right and make it feel like it's uh it's
a scary place so
yeah because with these elements with
immersion and the interactivity
it comes over now when that sparks of
electricity it's and you see all those
things bouncing on you etc it reinforce
the potential jump scare moment of that
thing it's not just audio and the cool
vfx or no a3 also has impacts on you and
oh
it's part of the physics system so it
reacts properly to whatever rules we
have within the game with the character
with the collision so
like greg said in the video that's what
makes it so amazing and so embedded and
just enhances the immersion for every
element that we're adding
yeah i mean certainly anyone that's
accidentally set themselves on fire with
an angle grinder while working in the
shop
is what we're going for
but hey you know they're they're when
people were noticing in that zero g they
were they were noticing some things
about isaac's suit and i think uh i
think we get to have a bit of a closer
look at the uh at the changes that have
been made to isaac suit coming up yep
we're gonna get to see that uh
in the next section in fact so
uh let's take a look at the the
character uh video so we could see what
all the changes we're making and up all
the upgrades to the uh engineering suit
and then we'll get a take a look at the
slasher so let's take a look at the
video
hello everyone i'm sam compenger and i'm
the lead character artist on the dead
space remake i'm here today to give you
a sneak peek on how we created the isaac
intermediate engineer suit the slasher
and talk about our artistic process and
our tools
before i get started i'd like to warn
you that i will be showing some graphic
content there will be blood and guts
well everything that makes that space so
lovely
let's start with isaac intermediate
engineer suit
during the early phase of our project we
took inspiration from the legacy model
and we followed the rules that made
isaac suit so iconic looking at the
ribbing that is inspired by gothic
architectures and human anatomy the
three lines on his helmet
and the overall layered look that remind
us this is a worker's outfit and not
military uniform
this was the thinking we used as we
redesigned the suit for our remake we
were tempted to go in a science fiction
direction but kept the suit design
low-tech dusty dirty and
greasy we kept in mind that the suit was
produced by a greedy corporation like
cec and was built in an utilitarian way
with a low production cost
and so here we are with the new design
making it functional and as you can see
we made sure the suit was airtight at
the seams to make it feel believable for
use in outer space
here we are in zbrush where the
character model is scripted as if it was
formed by digital clay this is where we
do most of our scripting and where we
spend most of our time creating the
character
the ad is worked in a separate file and
in a different way as it is based on of
gunners rights ad scan it is based on of
gunners rights add scan and come with
all his facial expressions
the helmet is worked on separately as
well because of the size of the file as
it tends to slow us down
as you can see here we walked on the
outside and inside of the helmet so
since you already saw isaac in game on
the previous live stream i will use this
time to take you on a tour of simpson's
painter which is a texturing software
there are plenty of layers to get to the
final result it goes from the base of
the fabric to the dirt and many metal
variation this is here as well that we
add micro detail like fabrics and grain
the design of the suit was purposely
kept low cost we also avoided raw
material like leather due to its rarity
on earth in the dead space universe
we used instead synthetic material and
learned metal that oxidized quickly we
took as reference real world minor from
the surveys unlike them that space
universe miner are given cheap outfit
because company didn't equip them well
and didn't care about their safety
now that we've seen isaac's suit i'd
like to show you a slasher since there
is always one waiting around the corner
or busting out of a vent
we researched the legacy concept and
model taking note what made the slasher
memorable enemy with its close-shaped
arm and deformed body
not only the design itself was important
to our new slasher but it was equally
important to make it satisfying to
dismember and peel away its layers
here are some visual developments on how
we wanted to dismember the slasher from
its intact state to the fully destroyed
one with all the phases in between some
peeling dismemberment with hanging parts
and finally the fully dismembered
version
so we started to think about the inside
this is the part that will be revealed
when you shoot at the necromorphs
naturally we want it to expose its
internal organs since this was the base
of our recipe then so it bones muscles
and fat
we didn't want it to see all the muscles
as it's only supposed to reveal a
wounded part made by isaac's tools
the next question we asked ourselves was
how could we build a system that fit
most of the necromorph well the solution
was to cut it in pieces
as you can see all the parts are
separated this way we could use them as
we wanted like for the brute which is
made of three humans we can easily kit
batch its skeleton this way
all internal organs are also supported
this way we could use them as we wish
now that we covered the inside of the
slasher let's see where we are with the
outside we scripted it in zbrush
thinking about how the skin stretch and
thor adeliem grew up very quickly during
a very painful transformation
the layering is important here as well
as what the open wound will reveal we
have the skin fat muscle cartilage bones
and we need to see and understand each
part
now i will jump straight into painter
just like for isaac and all our model we
scripted them in zbrush but here the
texturing and materials are more
interesting
first while we are currently only
showing a single skin tone since the
ishimura is crewed by human from all
corners of the galaxy it makes sense
that our slasher reflect a wide range of
ethnicities in the final game you will
notice that will reduce the amount of
blood and dirt present before you start
shooting at it to enhance the visual
feedback of the peeling process
finally let me show you how we texture
this little fellow adding layers and
layers of details to make it more
realistic
we start with a plain color as base and
then we add some layers that will have
an influence on the reflection color and
micro volumes
we took care to think about how the
wounded skin would look like bloody but
yellowish when it's dried off blood then
we added some more subtle details like
veins molds and pimples
and to finish
let's add
well you've already guessed what
blood
thank you for watching i hope you
enjoyed seeing the isaac suit and the
slasher work in progress
you gotta love that even in production
of the game you have to keep the parts
of the necromorph separated otherwise
you'll have neck remotes running all
over your computer you won't be able to
get anything done in zbrush and
necromorph will be swiping at you
you got to keep them separated
more and more blood
yeah more blood more always more
more we want more here
yes
that's all they call
[Laughter]
hey never satisfied
we've got a saying over at bangor tv
less is not more more is more and love
seeing that in a dead space game as well
i mean the the the peeling effects the
ripping effects it it seems subtle but
it's it's such a massive
you're left with a gamepl it's like it's
an entirely new enemy uh at what point
in the development process did you kind
of realize hey maybe we could do
something like this
pretty early i mean yeah it was quite
quite early on it came almost at the
beginning of the project
and
the idea was like okay so we were
looking at elements that we could uh
improve our our enhance in the original
and of course
dismemberment it's
the killer of that space it's in terms
of gameplay it's the main thing so term
of precision in the original and that's
basically it's pretty it's already
pretty precise so we're like okay maybe
we can go a bit more precise but yeah
it's not gonna add that that extra
impact and so that's where we d we
started to discuss okay
let's add the precision not in terms of
how you cut enemies but in term of the
point of impact so that's where we
started thinking and earlier on we we
did not call that peeling we were
actually calling that body destruction
because it was that concept that we
wanted to see precisely the point of
impact and we wanted to see pieces of
enemies flying and so give the
opportunity to the player to really dig
up to the bone before starting to catch
the the necromancer and so that's where
we started and iterating from here
that's where we go okay so we need
peeling layers with
flesh muscles internal organs that can
get blown out when you shoot them in the
belly or in there those kind of
and
the goal behind that was like yes of
course to make it more gruesome extra
but quickly on we figured that we were
also improving something really core to
the gameplay which is the feedback you
have
when you shoot an enemy because in that
space in the original you get a lot of
good feedback when you're shooting an
enemy with a with a cutting weapon like
with the plasma cutter you cut body
parts exterior you get a strong sense of
okay how much damage i did
but when you're using the flamethrower
and you're starting to burn the opponent
how much damage did you get when you're
using the force gun you shoot at him the
necromorph goes on his ass you stand up
okay how effective was that thing to the
necromorph now you get pretty good
feeling pretty strong feedback of that
because you see the flesh burning and
then you start to see the muscle
underneath it etc when you're using the
foreskin you and the guy stands up and
you see that all the flesh is gone and
the muscle is gone and no you can see
the bones and the rib cage you're like
yeah okay
i did some damage here that worked yeah
that's really the goal here and there's
a lot of research that we did also uh uh
looking at uh lots of gore and you know
bloody stuff uh i don't want to see you
yeah just just yeah just taking a couple
of trips a couple of trips to the
butcher shop leaving with a big bag of
organs sorry i i do do you know where a
hardware store is i need some hammers
yeah we're on a list somewhere
uh so yeah and we did a lot of
explorations early on we did we really
pushed it quite far make it like really
bloody really disgusting
and it was a lot of fun but we also
wanted to make sure that it was readable
that it didn't get too complex and too
detailed
and it could still read in that
environment and i think we found a
pretty good balance so uh yeah we're
really psyched to have shown you those
uh
results today pretty cool yeah yeah and
then just all the all that all the
language involved in the in the in the
remake of dead space is so great just
coming home uh honey good news the
budget approved body destruction
lots of glistening parts
the expense reports that are hard to do
but i managed
yeah um so uh one of the other things
that was this just such a little detail
but really kind of brings back to that
lived in world pillar you're talking
about is uh
a detail that just jumped out to me when
you're saying it you're going through
isaac's suit and you're you're
mentioning that there's there's no
leather on it because
cows are gone and if you've got leather
you're you're pretty rich
exactly exactly we always have to factor
that in right even though we can do
something uh even though we have the
tech even though we you know we could do
that it doesn't necessarily mean we
should we have to look at uh the
narrative of the game uh think of
resource conservation uh and always uh
plan and design with that in mind and
that's something that we did like early
on
his suit had those leather parts we go
yeah but he wouldn't really have that so
we went with a synthetic material that
still you know looks like it but uh it
has to be more accurate so there's a lot
of thought that's put into every single
thing that you see on the suits to make
it more functional to make it more
credible more realistic
but as always respecting the original
vision the art direction and being true
to that right
yeah i mean and i'm sure cosplayers are
going to thank you for the lack of use
of leather
but they're going to be really mad when
they find out that those there's little
thrusters on his back that move as he's
going around in zero g sorry
it's fun in the game
good details
now it's obviously really hard to follow
up something like characters and uh
you've got lighting as the as the last
the kind of the the big pillar to close
out the show and it might seem a little
surprising to people but i i think when
you show all the stuff you've done with
lighting they're going to kind of really
understand why we're going there yes yes
we got we have a really really cool uh
lighting video to show
and you're going to see that the behind
the scenes of how we're making it all
the different light fixtures that are
used color temperatures the mood and
feeling so
let's take a look at that
hello my name is mike yeomans and i'm a
lighting lead here at motive today my
teammates and i are going to talk a bit
about the lighting on dead space remake
first of all we're going to talk about
how we are recreating the fantastic
lighting design of dead space 1.
we'll follow up with our lighting
process and advances in real-time
lighting
and lastly we'll show you how we create
an immersive sense of atmosphere which
is an important visual pillar for us
dead space had iconic design down to the
last detail and the lighting fixtures
weren't left out of this equation they
just felt unique and that they fit into
the design of the ship perfectly we have
reimagined the lighting design of the
ishimura and valor staying true to the
originals while creating additional
fixtures that fit into this established
direction
the fixture design feels modern while
the bulb technology feels grounded in
the present day
we are creating the illusion of depth in
our fixtures so you can see the inner
workings of the bulb beyond the glass
using emissive shaders with a parallax
effect the brightness of the fixture
respects the intensities of their real
world counterparts and our lighting
system uses the surface area of our
emissive surfaces to determine how
bright the bulbs get
our volumetric lighting creates
realistic cones of light that are unique
to each fixture design so we get really
interesting shards of light with a hint
of color
much like in the real world we use
kelvin temperature to determine the hue
of our lights so once again they feel
familiar to what you would expect in
real life
area lights were previously reserved
mostly for cinematics due to their
increased performance cost
we are using them more extensively in
dead space remake as they help to create
convincing specular shapes diffused
lighting and shadows and a more accurate
volumetric shape
simply put they have lighting qualities
that standard spotlights just can't
achieve
area lights make the most sense for
rectangular looking light fixtures such
as signage it would have been hard to
reproduce the lighting from these types
of sources with more punctual lights
hi my name is matthew tedrow and i'm a
senior lighting artist on dead space
remake our lighting artists are able to
craft the lighting in real time and
control exactly how much indirect light
or global illumination is bouncing
around the scene
in previous game we had to do offline
calculation to precompute lighting and
apply it to geometry in the form of
light maps this was time consuming for
artists and will limit any drastic
lighting changes
our remake is using a new gpu probe
system which allows real-time
approximation of enzymatic light
artists can get direct feedback from the
change and can better match the amazing
concept art
our tools allow lighting artists to
visualize individual lighting passes and
material properties to isolate issues
and iterate on quality
as each light is activated and dialed in
we can see the bounce lighting react in
real time
this approach was essential to ensure we
can accommodate all the drastic lighting
changes that occur in real time in front
of the player
scary lighting changes
quarantine
light flickering
we place fixture in the ship much like
it would have been assembled in a
shipyard
then we'll give an area a distinct
character by changing the behavior and
setting on each fixture instance
this allow each area to have its own
signature mood ambience and level of
horror
we focus on developing credible light
behavior such as flickering that is
specific to different type of light from
fluorescent to incandescence and
allergen
imagine a fluorescent light tube
constantly flickering while trying to
turn on
in this video we can see how the
electrical current is driving the
behavior of different fixture technology
from fluorescence to incandescent
hi i'm guyon gudo i'm a lead outsource
slider on dead space team in game
development we often use fog to help
simulate atmospheric perspective and add
ambience to a level
it is used to communicate a sense of
depth and detach the different element
of the background
in dead space the atmosphere of the ship
is one of the key contributor of the
sense of horror
to create that atmosphere we've gone one
step further we are putting a lot of
energy into creating a realistic
volumetric fog solution
first we need a lot of control to create
the dreadful atmosphere expected in dead
space
with our system we can simulate a
layered fog approach
we have control over the texture that
move and shift inside of the fog
we can control the speed of the movement
and detail in the texture
we can recreate a fog creeping along the
floor
we have also control over the absorption
it gives the feeling of a thick dense
smoke that absorb light
very much like the smoke that collect on
the ceiling during a fire
we can also control the color of the fog
for those moment when we need a little
extra punch second
we need a convincing light interaction
with the fog
when we combine our lighting and the fog
we immediately see the impact
we can easily sculpt and tweak the shard
of light cutting across the room
it really adds a lot to a scene we can
go from the simplest environment to a
gloomy looking scene
lastly we need something flexible
whenever we have a big change and we
need to adjust the mood of the scene
we can animate and adjust the
environment fog
this is especially useful when we do
transition from the inside of the usg
ishimura to the outside
we will be able to contrast the heavy
ambience of our interior with the
complete lack of atmosphere in the outer
space
boy oh man
i can't
i can't i can't believe there's some
poor soul on the ishimura who has to
inventory every single different type of
light bulb you put in there i don't know
who has a harder job isaac or the light
bulb guy yeah poor guy all the guys that
we are in the ship oh my god
it's the future so energy
saving energy like that's
it's what is needed there
i definitely want to open a node door
and not have any treasure in there just
a wall full of different light bulbs
just racks and racks
so uh the thing about lighting though is
from from the stuff you've shown the the
the amazing stuff i've gotten to see it
it really seems like
the
narrator in dead space is lighting and
you're kind of using it almost as a
silent character yes
yeah absolutely and and that's how we're
crafting uh all of our our scenes right
like we we purposely will set the seed
making sure that the lights are placed
in the right areas and also as you as
you saw in the video
uh
there's different types of lights light
fixtures temperatures so that we can uh
control and craft the experience that
the player has in every area
and we also use lighting to
direct the player to where we want him
to go either for objectives or to where
we want him to go either for objectives
but also sometimes to to surprise the
person with either like a jump scare or
not like drive the
uh like the tension up just playing with
expectations player expectations so
that's what lighting is used for uh by
our team and it's just
yeah and i also noticed one really
subtle thing about lighting is that uh
one of the the few the the sparse few
criticisms of the original game is that
it it was very brown um and it seems
like there's a lot of use of light to
kind of add change mood a little bit of
color without going overboard because
obviously i mean even just to something
as subtle as going from a warm light to
a cold light and i went from looking
like i'm in a cozy basement to like i'm
ill right
so yeah all these little splashes of
color that don't break the kind of drab
scary feeling but kind of give you that
little bit of visual breakup through it
exactly yeah and and that's it like we
still wanted to retain that horror uh
pillar like i said earlier is that uh
making sure that we don't
you know in an effort to add more
diversity to all the different areas uh
we didn't want to you know be too
saturated too colorful uh but
just have enough emotion and you know
play with the intensity of the lights um
so that we have more of that that
feeling of variety in the different
levels
we're adding more tools to make sure
that each room is used
more
like more cookies
all right you're on to me
and i
you know in in true horror fashion uh
we'd not we didn't have one fog
presentation we had two fog
presentations i mean silent hill fans in
the chat we're really happy to hear how
much fog work we're getting what's the
kind of difference between the the two
frogs and the one you kind of showed
here where are you going to use that how
is that going to be applied
but if you ever played the original that
space you know that we had to to work
hard on the fog because there's a lot of
those in the game it's used a lot for
different to create different ambience
and stuff and so that's why we felt we
need those two different pieces of
technology one that is a bit more
diffused that we use in in bigger
environments like the engine room
chapter 3 of this kind of environment
but to create that depth and be able to
have those different layers of lights
and stuff and one like we talked before
really for specific moments specific
ambience where we want
maybe smaller room with a bigger feel of
uh being isolated and uh and
alone inside that room where the fork
the fog story is going to be more
advanced and we'll be able to play a bit
more with it
and uh and and and from from what i
understand we might actually get to get
to see some of that uh happening in in
did dare i say dare i say in game in
games maybe
soon maybe i think i think we also have
a little bit we get the uh we're getting
a little uh uh collector's edition
treatment here we've also got some uh
some pretty gorgeous concept art that
i've seen in the show the people to get
to get them to get them uh uh
all all excited all on edge before we
give a little game play
yes absolutely so what i wanted to do is
i want to show some cool concept art of
the engineering deck
but just very quickly before i do that i
want to take this moment to thank the
art team
for all their hard work
they're super super passionate about
working on this game they put in a lot
of hours and there's a lot of love and
care in making sure that we get this
right we do justice to the original and
we honor it so we're super pac super
fans ourselves and we hope that that
comes through and the work that you're
seeing today
so once again thank you team
so um
to kick it off so here's the concept art
of the fuel depot to show you
how the pillars of horror immersion and
lived-in world all come together
in this industrial themed chapter so i'm
just going to quickly go through them
here you could see the fuel storage
concept
you can see the machine shop
and time and time again we're always
applying those same rules with lighting
vfx
fog
volumetrics
so this is the first concept of the
machine room
and then here's one more we love just
you can see the suits hanging the suit's
on the right give me that give me that
yeah i'll take one that's it we're
always thinking of how the crew would
work and live on the ishimura to make it
yeah exactly make it credible and lived
in
and then the last two concepts i just
wanted to show was of the engine room so
this is one of the most iconic areas in
that
the chapter three engineering deck and
so here it is in the off state
it's looking very dark it's very ominous
and then here it is in the on state as
you can see we're dialing up the
intensity
by using color and light to show the
visual progress and build emotion
and bring this area to life
so like we said at the start um
we're still pre-alpha however what we're
going to show right now in game
is actually something that we have spent
a bit of time polishing like if we were
saying that this is uh pre-alpha it
wouldn't be entirely true there's been
some work done by our team to bring it
to l4 to have a
higher level of quality so this is
closer to the evolve quality that we'd
expect for the entire game
there's still some work left on our side
uh but yeah i'm pretty sure
not yet really to shape that not ready
to ship but but it's getting closer yeah
i love referring to the footage remember
to see that they were not even the
footage the live gameplay we're about to
see as pre-alpha it's it's uh it's
doesn't look pretty alpha to me
all right let's look at the engine room
it's in a specific state in the sense
that all the ai got removed etc so it's
really to showcase the uh the
environment so if we can switch to the
engine game play please
thank you
and then of course the goal with this is
that we wanted to show all of you how
you know we've crafted this this story
you know how all the different elements
develop my name is mike
presentation
uh
we have the video of lights playing at
the same
that's the time
okay that's some fantastic lighting
yeah absolutely there we go
yeah
so just like we saw in the concept it's
dark uh it's really hard to see what's
out there and we do that on purpose to
contribute to the fear of the unknown
right you don't know what's back there
or we're doing that on purpose but then
just there's just a little bit of uh
life in there just so that it's not
completely dead seen
and then as we look above us we see the
the massive engine
uh and it's again it makes us feel small
and insignificant right it's looming
so
as we're looking around we see all those
effects that you saw earlier in gyms now
you see it here steam coming out of the
pipes there's some secondary animation
with the moving pistons it gives life
you know it communicates that this is an
industrial thematic
and then we're always
leading the player with a little bit of
horror storytelling a little bit of
narrative we have the various tools and
crates
i love the masks on sign up there yeah
quite thematic safety first let's face
this game about safety
okay so in this state uh now
now we're in a state where it's starting
to you know we've powered the
room
so the engine is slowly starting to
rotate
a little bit of life to it
yeah it's uh let's follow the blood
trail then let's do that
no
it's always a good idea
so here we go this is the iconic
poster that we saw earlier you can see
the different treatments on the blood
like the one that is still wet
blood that's got dried up on the side
more is more more types of blood more
blood states more blood conditions yeah
and then we finally get here
uh and we're
gonna activate the engines
turn it on let's turn it
and we look up above us and then we can
see this
glorious you know vfx
the engine's fully operational it's open
it's spinning at full speed it's like a
it's like a beating heart uh the room
has come to life and we have completed
transformation
and then as we look to the right we
witnessed the scene of a horrific
bloodbath
and uh
yeah
some bad stuff happened there
again just that just that great great
teamwork between the environment artists
and the story artist like i mean you can
really you you can guess what happened
there
and then we're back into darkness as we
make our way down and then we take one
last look
at the engine and then the smoke-filled
room
and that's it
there's those sparks yeah
and that's it for today we're gonna save
some stuff for later
okay so
this is it's so you know like i said you
know you've been you've been showing a
lot of this to us uh for a long time now
and man seeing that seeing the
improvement every time and just how
amazing it's looking right now i can't
believe i can't believe that's not like
a finished product you know i can't
believe there's there's more work you're
going to do in there it seems impossible
that's the reason why we usually send
these guys on press store there's always
more work so at one point
go away we have to wrap this up
yeah if they're talking to me they can't
be talking to anyone on the team tell
them to put more stuff in the game that
room is pretty playable there's a really
cool fight situation i think it's just
deactivated for the reason of that
stream because we want to keep some more
surprise for later but i think you have
something to say about that soon but uh
yes that like we said we're pre-alpha so
it's the game is currently fully
playable and yes that fight is [ __ ]
awesome
well definitely
all right well i i guess we're actually
nearing the end of the stream so uh
lane i i want to thank you for being
like with us today to to discuss ask
your questions away it was great having
you uh and and thank you for taking part
we're actually going to see you next
week right so yeah see you in person i'm
going to get i'm going to get a little
get a little hands-on action i'm really
excited uh thanks so much for including
me i mean you know any opportunity i
have to just uh gush about this game
whether it's the first one or the work
you're doing right now uh uh i'll gladly
take any i can so thanks so much thank
you so much
thank you
uh roman mike
thanks a lot like it's always great to
see all of this come together uh for you
to take part of this mike i know it was
a lot of work for you our team to
create all of these videos to create uh
this amazing uh playable level so thank
you
uh it is important
to be able to show the artwork oh for
sure
like we're here standing and looking
smart but it's like the team that
actually did all the work so so it's
important to actually state that
i want to thank the team the team at
motive everyone from the art but
everyone that works on the project uh
our internal ea partners our external ea
partners
the passion the love the the hard work
that you're putting in in this game it
really shows and i hope that everyone
that's watching today actually can
recognize uh all the care and love
that's going into creating those nice
slashers
and those nice moments
um
at this point like i said earlier um
when you started the stream were we we
were able two weeks ago to do our first
full walk through the entire game all
features the chapter structure some
novelties that we haven't yet talked
about uh it was all there for us to play
um our directors roman mike everyone the
lead the team were able to exchange on
all right what's next like how can we
improve what we already have
to be able to to get an even higher
quality game
from this we're able to take all of
these notes and plan the work that's
ahead of us make sure that we have a
smart way to tackle all of this to bring
the game to a conclusion
so that's basically where we're at so
from a team perspective we're going to
put our head down and work towards the
next objective that we have which is
going to be to do our gameplay reveal in
october let's say close to halloween ish
so that's going to be the next time
where we're going to be broadcasting and
talking about the game in a more
substantial way
also we're we're actually in the
position right now to be able to say
that well
our release date of january 27 2023 is
kind of right around the corner it's
getting by really fast we're getting
there
and we're definitely looking forward to
be able to put the game in the hands of
players so mark your calendars um tell
your friends make sure that they know
that the game's coming because
we want this game to be a success we we
love that space so hopefully you're able
to get that word out and hopefully you
love that space oh hopefully you love
what we make for the remake so uh i
guess that's a wrap uh thank you for
watching the live stream uh we're going
to read comments we're going to read the
feedback that you have
hopefully there's plenty and we're more
than happy to have shown you a slice of
the game today so thank you for your
time thank you very much
hope you enjoyed the show bye-bye cheers